I'm going to work welcome to this video
me fish is the opponent to never play
them I never ending stream of good
players here on the ICC yeah that line
is getting back into fashion 91 this is
the the old main line oh this one hmm
yeah this is something that I have
plagued myself when I was a kid I chief
online i have not entirely sure what the
current state is there i think still
this regrouping is played okay so it's
not be five now coming i can go Bishop
d7 for the moment queen bee three though
when use this idea oh no well okay i
cannot really take me seven so maybe i
can do this prevent not be five for the
moment with the bishop 1 f 2 ok so it's
yeah it's kind of it's it's a serious
IDNR be five
hmm ok I think I'm checking their first
if he goes to be five I mean he has to
maybe also worried about some things on
the file down so after night h4 he wants
to take I guess hmm hmm well the dark
squares are not looking great then that
doesn't look like an issue at the moment
but it's still something to consider
okay I think I'm taking it would be
excellent of course if I would get the
bishop over get the bishop over to like
be six or so it's it looks unlikely
though or sounds unlikely to happen okay
but i think i can go rook c8 for the
moment with a dark squared Bishop gonna
ever a bit more relaxed about some
endings so yeah that should be kind of
okay in this position okay so you want
to invade them and maybe
okay angling for p5 and OB 525 looks
wrong for what maybe you wants to go if
I of course have a 505 something like
that not quite sure why is going with it
at the end but gaining some space is
probably not a bad idea thinking about
Quincy eight now looks at c3 and also
looks at g4 so in some cases I might be
able to okay i was thinking Quincy age
should be fine isn't it
so we just trade stuff so it's queen is
really far off the area let's see can I
do something sacrificing a piece then on
yet not yet I think
king of seven is mostly awaiting move I
would love to get rid of that Queen in
the first place with Bishop d8 but he
can take these six at the moment that's
a bit annoying I can do this for Bishop
d8 then possibly be 60 k OB 5v5 is also
interesting move he certainly doesn't
want to take if I go p6 less maybe night
c4 so let's to be five
yeah now I mean it's pretty passive to
be honest can do why he doesn't have
many constructive ideas well I can try
to shuffle my bishop over to a 7 95 or
something like that that could be an
idea actually but I don't have yeah so
we actually had an idea so I can go back
though right time when he's a self pin
so
i wonder if i can sacrifice it's
certainly close so let's let's let's go
for that with no time on the clock I
didn't want to take the night giving him
the initiative night is still hanging
that that adds to this situation and it
cannot really move that right given
opening up the diagonal for my bishop is
probably pretty awful okay so i can a
couple of ideas actually checking is not
good okay oops so much that i will just
take him
yeah bit more time would be good and
it's not premium don't have enough time
maybe you can just go Quincy to all
something like that no it's giving this
chick
hmm I really don't know where spend all
that time check okay so I'm definitely
all right now I mean I should should win
a bad position but the time check check
check check check
check check check check check check
check check check jam I don't shine
don't have a good face here at this
massager black for one time Jim bad run
again never should lose that just bad I
don't know where did I spent all that
time I mean I don't really know how I
said the more comfortable position in
this game it wasn't much time to spend
ready on moves I me okay he played all
that all that stuff pretty much
instantly well I took at least some time
to consider things okay I could have
taken on g4 he already but I think I
played that all right now the bishop
comes over there and yeah 95 is an
interesting idea and even though we came
so Bishop g4 was winning the game
directly yeah it's always hard to tell
you have no time to calculate it out
something like this is pneus check check
its deadly yeah he doesn't have any
square to be honest he cannot go on the
H file due to the Queen move and King F
294 just wins the Queen straightaway so
if 96 is not possible 93 is pretty
pretty strong yes sir the good thing
also would have been a bit quicker
chanting quicker to play a queen d
five is just don't understand the move
Queen c2 is quite obviously the only
idea for Quincy seven chat yeah and here
black complexion but yeah cherry know
the deal chang and chang and check don't
know it's it's a draw but again i don't
really know I've got a bad time
management here in those last two or
three games okay it was basically
instant moving all the time that that
sometimes an issue if they really move
immediately and you do some commentary
you will really you will spend some time
and it adds up a little bit I was pretty
quick there now here I was thinking
about b6 be fine now I was I was quick
enough p.m. here it took a bit of time
added that that stupid writin to take
this long here for for this move i have
to take only six anyway it was a pretty
bad idea now okay thanks for watching